[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez transports en
commun parisiens est sans limites et il
devrait être un peu plus développés se
sont plus adaptés à la population
parisienne
c'est à dire c'est à dire qu'ils seront
blindés ils sont souvent en panne ou
enfin ils sont plus adaptés du tout à la
population parisienne et autres elle n
en pense quoi
mon frère mon transport
c'est pour qui pour ces huit de pmp anna
alors je bosse au csa nous voit trois
millions voulait sans rimes
je pense qu'on a un bon choix entre les
transports plus belle
les taxis g7 et sert à quoi je pense que
les choix est large et votre elle en
pince moi j'ai pas expert mais
renouvelle sa cp reçoit alain prost ça
mais avec une tonne de sable a
d'ailleurs connu encore les transports
en commun parisiens sont on va dire bien
peut-être un peu on peut voir paris
l'ensemble
j'aime à dire assez c'est pas mal et
l'auxois l'on pense quoi lasserre c'est
la pensée des blondes mais c'est les
plans de carpentras de cartes connaissez
peut-être on en a fait des ravages au
macumba
on a des fausses couches et des vraies
envies si l'enfer et pour le reste ça
pourrait être mieux quand même
voilà et c'est surtout super cher voilà
c'est comment
[Musique]
non non par rapport au service rendu
c'est super cher et 200 ballots
bonneteau la mégane joue avec les cards
la rouge la noire la rougeanne sommes
une même a pris 200 balles vous n'êtes
pas frères non je crois pas à l'homme il
ya un gag 200 balles ça suffit cette
méthodes gelé vu en zone interdite en
plus six médailles de la vie d'ardian je
suis fait avoir mais on a berné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]